George's in Chicago
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show George
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up amen
so I thought your book the Total Money
Makeover in December of 2017 I read it
in about a week and then you know
starting January of 2018 I was like hey
babe let's do this and she was in line
with me we did so for the last I don't
know 14 months we've been on it's odd
following your order your principles
verbatim the only thing I can't convince
her to do and I I don't want to get into
an argument with her it was cut off the
one credit card we have which doesn't
have a balance I think she's just
holding on foot for like Security's sake
okay
well I I think you're right and I think
you need to not think let's ask her why
is it that you want to hold the card and
that's not an intimidating sarcastic
question okay it's an honest question
we're just sitting here quietly going
help me understand because we're winning
but more than we've ever won with money
we've had a great year and why is it you
want to keep this particular card okay
okay and if she says something like well
I've had it since college well it's not
an old boyfriend it's a card why do you
want to keep the card okay because I've
had it since college is not a real
reason right although sometimes people
give me that reason I think you'll find
it is one of two things it almost always
boils down to this and I think you've
already hit on it I think number one
thing is it's a security blanket if
something goes wrong I've got this okay
and I think you'll find that okay and if
you find that then I'll type we'll talk
about that a second the second time
thing that comes up is if her vote in
the budget committee meeting her voice
is not being heard because in your
enthusiasm you're being overbearing mmm
she may be holding it as a power play
because I always got this option if big
George turns the screws down too tight
because he's a wee bit enthused about
this Dave crap okay so sometimes
time's that one comes up and that's a
valid thing to which you know the answer
to that is obvious that your voice needs
to be heard more and if you find that
out that's a really healthy thing to
find out that you can adjust your
approach to the budget committee meeting
where her vote has an equal voice in the
budget committee meeting I don't think
it's what it is I think it's security I
think you already know your wife and
you've already guessed which one it is
so I think it's number one the way to
solve that then is okay what amount of
money in the emergency fund or what
amount of years of us managing the money
perfectly like we've been doing for a
year would it take for you to feel
comfortable cutting that up because at
some point you know let's say you had a
million dollars cash in your checking
account to hold a credit card for
security would be absolutely asinine
yeah okay so then you can go backward
from there and just go is it ten
thousand dollars you know I mean you
know at what point and she may just go
okay well once we've been managing money
well for two years because we got 20
years of sucking at it then I'll just be
comfortable and I'll cut it up and we
got one year in then you go okay we have
an agreement then at the end of the year
if we're still on track you're gonna cut
it out or she may say when we get the
emergency for under 20 thousand I'll be
willing to cut it up okay let me tell
you what will happen if she says that
yeah and you get an agreement on that
you say okay we're gonna cut it up at
twenty thousand when we get the
emergency fund there when you get to
about ten thousand she'll probably chop
it well because she's seeing things
going the right way but you've got
however many years of your marriage
doing it wrong versus one year of doing
it right and so you're rebuilding trust
in yourself as well as in her as you
guys are handling this money does that
make sense that makes perfect sense
thank you David yes I I agree with you I
would not be it would not be a hill I
would die on today but I do want
clarification on it and I want an end
date based on a base taun a number some
kind some objective measure not when I
feel like it that's just being childish
and that's what is it you want from this
and what is it we can do to replace what
you want so that you can do away with
this thing okay and and I think it's
gonna be size of emergency fund I think
that's what it's going to
and of course we're in complete
agreement you're not using the stupid
thing you're getting out of debt not in
and you said you're carrying a zero
balance but I wouldn't even have it out
of the wallet I just put it in the
drawer and then you do all your
transactions with debit cards cash and
the occasional check and online transfer
but zero use of the credit card now
that's that's not negotiable I will have
a fight about that we've got to stop
using a stupid thing it's a crutch and
so you've got to break that once you
break that then you say okay what's the
what do we replace it with and what is
it security is it power and let's
replace it it almost always falls in one
of those two categories